[Music]  I've never seen a man cup before it's so  smooth  [Music]  Kyra  boy you are special little brother  you've got hands so let's use a pulse  push be with other words it's not was  I've seen the way you look at the  village welcoming you are one of them  [Music]  I've ever wanted just long you will  always be my son Mowgli nothing can ever  change that  the jungle is changing  man is taking more of it and boy may  just be our only hope of survival we're  afraid of what now I do to us the pack  needs you  my how you've grown  I am NOT a man but neither am i awards  which of you will follow me  man cos the whole jungle has been  watching me  I love failed  you  you